(audience applauding)
- My gosh.
(indistinct)
I know, you look so good.
Have y'all ever met?
- We have not.
- Okay.
- No we haven't.
- But what an honor.
- I'm like, Jesus, just
bringing people together.
Okay, so, so I have to ask you.
This is the craziest story to me.
So you are from Atlanta?
- I am, born and raised.
- And then you're in a, where,
where does the jump to go
to Korean competition show?
Where, what happened there?
- This is a story.
- Okay.
- Okay, so go to school,
graduate, get a job
at Deloitte Consulting doing
strategy, ask for a year off.
And I went to India to do
service work, essentially.
And while I was there, I got a email
through a YouTube video
that a TV show I'd watched.
And I thought it was a scam.
And it said like, "Hey, come to Korea.
"Send us your passport."
What happens when you do that?
You lose your identity.
- Send us your passport.
- Yes and I was like, this is gonna,
this is a scam.
- This is shady.
- But I was like I've always
wanted to do a music thing.
Why not just send just enough information
to see if they send me a flight?
And sure enough, they did.
So I get to Korea a few days later.
Started an audition program
very much like the one
you were on.
- Yeah.
- And then I got to the top
five, signed a record deal,
quit my job, and started
my career in music.
- Yeah, what a story.
(audience applauding)
To grow up in Atlanta.
And I just thought that was a crazy jump.
So, I hear they have a
nickname for you in Korea.
(Eric laughing)
I love this nickname.
Did you love it?
- It was, it was.
- The nation's boyfriend?
- Yeah.
I was like, do I say this myself?
- Nation's?
It's, I think it's, is it
the Nation's boyfriend?
- Yeah, I was called
the Nation's boyfriend.
- That's just like everyone's boyfriend.
I'm just, yeah.
The nation's boyfriend,
what does this mean?
Have you asked?
- I was told, so pretty much
in Korea there's a phrase
called (speaking in Korean).
So that means one Eric Nam per household.
So it's like.
(audience laughing)
It's like actually kind of
in like the dictionaries
and like if you search
it, it's like a thing.
- Oh, you're like Beyonce
with Bootylicious.
You just like made a word.
Like that's incredible.
- But here's the thing, I didn't make it.
I don't know who made it, but it was made
and then all of a sudden I
was on this fun reality show.
It was, you know, reality
where I'm fake married
for like nine months.
And through that and
through being on all these.
I know, I know, I know.
I know, I know.
- How did you like
being married?
How did you like being married?
- It was great.
- It doesn't stick for everyone.
(both laughing)
- Well, mine was like nine months.
- Okay.
- You know, again, it was -
- Some are, yeah.
- It was a.
- In reality
- Also true.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But it was fun.
But it was through doing a lot
of shows and I was on any
sort of TV show, radio show
anything, everywhere.
And I think people just
really saw me everywhere.
And I think people liked me in general.
And so I got
that name.
- You're very likable.
- Thank you so much.
- Yes, you are very likable.
- So "House on a Hill".
Where did this album title come from?
- I was wanting to buy a house
and I was looking all around.
I happened to find this
beautiful house in LA
and I was like, "This is the home."
And then I was like, "Wait,
but I'm never anywhere.
"Do I really need?"
- Yeah.
- To make this thing?
And then I thought of,
I went down this rabbit hole of thinking
about all the things that
we're told we need to be happy
or successful.
That is getting property
or having a certain family
or looking a certain way
or having all these things.
- You think if I do this, I'll be happy.
If I have this, yeah.
- But then I started to realize it's like
no matter what you have
you're always gonna
want the shiniest, the newest thing.
The upgrade and -
- Apple gets us every time.
- Every time they get us, right.
- It's the same damn phone.
- I don't stand
in line anymore though.
I'm not standing in line no more.
- I'm not standing in line.
- I'll order it on the.
- Yeah, wait til they work
out the kinks.
- Yes.
- You're right though.
That is true, like,
especially when we're younger.
We think like, "Oh, this
will make me happy."
Yeah.
- Yeah.
So that was kind of the
start of the process
which led me down a complete rabbit hole
of a existential crisis of sorts.
So just figuring out what makes me happy,
what makes me tick, what
makes me really wanna get
up every day and do what I do.
And that's kind of how
we built out the album,
trying to figure out some of those.
- So that house on a hill
you thought you wanted
wasn't really what you wanted?
Yeah.
- No, I think one day I do,
but right now I'm good.
I think it's enjoying
the process of creating,
of touring and meeting incredible
people like yourselves.
- Yeah.
Did you have that when you were younger?
I used to do that too.
Especially 'cause I grew up with no money.
Then they give you money and you're like,
"What do I do with this?"
And I would you, totally
end up buying stuff.
Like, "Oh, if I had this
house I've got in Texas.
"If I did this."
I definitely went through all of that.
Was not as smart as you.
Actually bought the house.
And just, you know, kind of
went through the motions.
Did you do that?
- I did, I did.
You know, because the American dream says
that you're supposed to,
you know, have a house
and 2.3 kids and, you know.
But I, and I felt bad about myself
for a long time 'cause I
was not a, I'm an artist.
- Yeah.
- You know, that's hand to
mouth, that's check to check.
So like I didn't amass enough funds
until I was 50 to buy
my first house, yeah.
- You have enough experience
in that, I think you probably
made way better decisions than I did.
- Well, I don't know about that.
'Cause I'm not really
that great with money so.
- It's important though
because society does tell you
like this is what you need to be happy.
This is what you need.
And everyone's different.
So I, yeah, you're very clever
and smart to be so young.
But we need to do another
commercial break, everybody.
Eric's tour and album and song
are called "House on a Hill".
You can find both online.